get 25% off a subscription to Babel by
clicking the link below Babel is an
awesome language learning app they're
one of our sponsors I use Babel to
improve my Italian and I'm loving the
results I'd recommend Babel to anyone go
check it out last week I told you that
you know things have gone off the beaten
path when we are judging how a president
is doing not by their approval rating
but by the level of support for their
impeachment which is the way that things
have shifted with Donald Trump but
there's an even more stunning metric
which is how many people want Donald
Trump imprisoned never mind
impeached and now a majority of
Democratic voters in those early primary
states the states that will be voting in
the first few months of 2020 they don't
just believe that Donald Trump should be
impeached but a majority of early
democratic primary state voters believe
that Donald Trump should be imprisoned
fifty-three percent in Iowa 50% in New
Hampshire 54 percent of Democrats in
South Carolina are saying not just that
Donald Trump should be impeached and
removed from office but that he should
be imprisoned now these are stunning
numbers but does this matter because
this is in the end just Democratic
primary voters they're some of the most
politically involved people arguably
some of the more partisan people that
you could pull does it really matter and
the answer is that in a vacuum
it really doesn't all of these
indicators are merely sort of proxies to
whether Donald Trump might be voted out
in November a record 69% for example say
that they dislike Donald Trump
personally okay does it matter it
matters if it gets people to go and vote
in November for somebody other than
Donald Trump
support for impeaching and removing
Donald Trump is higher than ever
even among Republicans as I told you
last week in the two weeks or so since
the beginning of the Ukraine Fiasco
support among Republicans for the
impeachment inquiry has roughly tripled
from about 11% to about 30 does that
matter well it matter
if it affects how people vote in
November of 2020 it matters if it keeps
enough Republicans from voting at all
that it will allow the Democratic base
to get somebody else elected other than
Donald Trump in November of 2020 in a
sense the headline majority of early
voters want Trump imprisoned could be
re-written much less hyperbolically as
majority of early voters can recognize
when crimes have been committed period
but unless it actually creates a certain
action in November of 2020 it's really
moot the entire fiasco is really
illuminating one of the most important
differences between Democrats and
Republicans which is that Democrats want
Trump held responsible impeached
investigated may be imprisoned whatever
you believe is appropriate for the
crimes that he's clearly committed for
the way that he has clearly sold out our
sovereignty to foreign powers
Republicans want Hillary Clinton
imprisoned because they don't like her
and Trump said lock her up and they've
been successfully brainwashed into
thinking something about her emails
means she should go to prison there's an
above the law component that's visible
here with Trump and his cronies that if
we don't root it out it could not only
take hold but it could grow and it's
terribly toxic for the United States of
America now you know I'm not someone who
just defends Democrats
I've told you on tons of issues there's
no practical difference between
Democrats and Republicans for the most
part on reinforcing the status quo of
campaign finance Democrats and
Republicans are basically the same with
some examples of exceptions Bernie's
plan to get money out of politics is a
very good one Andrew yang has such a
plan there are Democrats who have plans
but there's not a lot of air in terms of
like your mainstream elected officials
between the two parties on that issue
for the most part Democrats and
Republicans are almost equally complicit
in reinforcing the status quo of the
military-industrial complex and the
wide-reaching
tentacles of the Pentagon and the
American military there are some
exceptions but
there are areas of difference and I've
pointed out this one before when the
left finds out that someone in their
ranks is a problem we want to get that
person out because they're hurting the
movement they're a distraction we don't
want to cover it up we want to expose it
and get that person out sometimes to a
fault look at what happened with Al
Franken now in retrospect what are those
Democrats who said Al Franken should
resign probably it went too far on the
right
they want to cover it up they want to
cover for that person period and of
course the hypocrisy of thinking that
their people above the law are above the
law is a stark contrast with the
Democratic Party some may actually be so
disconnected from reality that they
really believe Donald Trump hasn't done
anything wrong
and Democrats are just being mean but I
believe at this point that most of them
are plainly happy to just cover for
Trump with any old excuse they can come
up with as illogical as that may be and
unless we get out and vote in November
of 2020 they well may get away with it
and that's the scariest part of all of
this make sure you are following the
david pakman show on instagram at david
pakman show while you're there follow me
at David Pakman